you have to remember the experience for
what it was for you
and what you got from it and the
challenges you faced and the job that
you did and sometimes the moment you
read someone else's negative opinion it
can completely
change your memory of what that
experience was and
so i think it's right to to
not look if you can can we just talk a
little bit about tone
because there's an interesting thing
going on with all
three performances jody particularly you
you had to sort of balance
you have to balance a kind of dead hat
deadpan humor
with violence and sort of thriller like
how how is the how does the balance work
for you
do you ever get a sense that you've gone
too far one way and need to kind of
bring yourself back in
or does it just come naturally to you
yeah no i mean like glenda said it's
like when you watch something back and
you're like oh my god like there's so
many moments that
i i have like that um and again
sorry like i kind of repeat myself as
before but i i do
heavily rely on i i'd rather direct it
go
a bit much take it down a peg oh you
know like you say you can dare to go a
little
bit further with that um and i guess
always
just focusing on there being truth in
what it is that you're doing
like yes it may be a little bit upset or
a bit outlandish but where is the truth
and does it feel authentic um i think
it's always what you have to try and
draw yourself
and yourself back to and saran you had
to do a really
unusual thing which i presume you
haven't done before which is that kind
of breaking the fourth wall where you're
talking directly
to camera how does that how easy is that
to do
how it can make you out of the character
and then throwing you back in
i think you have done i had to
understand it before i
um committed to it and what what sally
said is
how are we going to show um analyst is a
diarist so how are we going to show
diary entries and that's what the fourth
wall is doing
she is she's making a diary entry
so once i understood that it was it was
easy to
i'm talking to the book
to the page and and and it was okay but
i went through a lot of
um moments where i would wink at the
camera or i'd
do things and they and and i and they
i'd hear a big laugh
and i think oh no no that's not meant to
be funny i remember coming and go
that worked but not for what we want and
okay because it it's difficult because
i'm also
i'm i'm representing
um a section of society as well so it's
a
it's a very delicate like i want and to
be real
and um full of all these um
[Music]
questions and vulnerabilities um that
a woman of that time would have
exploring her gender and sexuality and
at the same time talking to the camera
and being
quirky and big and tipping my hat so
it's um but i don't i think it's only
sally could
kind of do that really you just got to
trust
and and also i think well if it doesn't
work
it's fine it's fine it's not the end of
the world
life goes on yeah yeah
then you had not dissimilar thing to
maneuver which is around interacting
with characters from the past
and characters from the present that
were either there or not there
can you talk a little bit about how much
i mean when you read that on the page
did you believe that that was going to
come off or was that something that you
had to kind of work out to get right
not really because
what you see in the film is the increase
of her fallibility i mean her illness
fallability
and so within that which encircles the
whole
action in the sense there are those
moments where
you know memory becomes more of a
reality
and because i think that was very
clearly marked and i could understand
that
it wasn't that big a problem as i said
the
the thing that i found most difficult to
get my head around was
how this essentially kind nice
ordinary woman could throw these
terrible
fits of rage and so the
the kind of medical evidence that its
frustration
was very helpful i think and of course
the obverse of that is
that also she
she pads out the comfort if you know
what i mean
they they're wildly over dressed in
truth
i mean i don't mean overdressed in the
costume sense but you know the memory
is much richer softer
more loving than it probably was when
the event actually occurred so that was
a kind of balance that i could
understand
my wife looked very beautiful in your
show
she's very good didn't she i was like oh
yeah so she's mine that era just suited
her
like yeah and she loves she knows
exactly how to stub out a cigarette
don't you oh yeah
i'm here dying out
beautiful singing voice yeah yeah
marvelous okay we've got lots of
questions coming in
and they're veering from one side to the
other so i'll just go from the top
um millie hansen would like to know any
advice on dealing with rejection
in the industry as an actress uh
sir do you want to kick us off with that
um i guess
i guess having so much of it when you
start off
is i i i've i learned at some points i
did some teaching
and did some audition techniques and um
i worked with a
um a company where i i did like musical
theater stuff
um courses and through through working
with other people i think
every time you audition
it's like it's like having a job so you
you get your script you go
you enjoy it for what it is and you walk
away and
there's so many factors that you that
um you might you just might not look
right you just might not
um have the right voice or you you know
you just might not
fit with who they've got in mind
they might have already cast but they
had to see a load of people to show
the um production company that they were
seeing people that i think it's just
enjoy
your meetings for what they are rather
than
hang everything on it all the time you
know it's hard when
as jody said before if i don't get this
part i'm not going to watch it because i
really want this part
so that's hard but every every audition
is um it's a step to something else
or is a discovery and and it's really
hard to learn that you can't just learn
that
um when you're starting out but i think
it's a good thing to try and remember
do you have any rejection advice glenda
well i'm not quite sure where her
rejection is cited
i mean if it's auditions or is it bad
notices
i mean if it's auditions i remember
i would go for auditions and go back a
very long way now
and i would spend at least a week
getting ready for this audition you know
i mean
just getting ready and i would walk into
the room this
is how it was in my day and there were
usually
a line of people sitting behind a table
in the room
and you'd walk through the door and the
voice would say oh thank you darling but
we're looking for a blonde
bye oh thank you darling we're looking
for some
guy and what you have to learn is it's
not personal they're not when you
as a person you just ain't right for the
job
um and that takes quite some time
to learn actually um on the other
rejection which is bad notices well you
just
eventually stop reading them
well you don't get many do you um
i was gonna say i think that's right
though glenda because i think
you have to remember the experience for
what it was for you
and what you got from it and the
challenges you faced and the job that
you did and
sometimes the moment you read someone
else's negative opinion it can
completely
change your memory of what that
experience was and
so i think it's right to to
not look if you can if
you can yeah um okay question from
michelle houghton who says
uh questions for everyone do you
remember if there's any a particular
character actor show or film or even a
specific
scene that inspired you or helped you
discover that you wanted to go into
acting as a career
surrounding that's of yours oh go on
jody go on i was actually
gonna say i remember watching um
samantha
in more more than color i think that was
a big
um that was like the first moment i was
like wow okay
this is you know it really kind of
spiked my interest and i think our
film's just beautiful
yeah well she's not here so you can tell
say something i know that's a joke
you give yours um
i think when when i discovered that
acting was a thing and um and that i
could put my energies
into into it with a group of like-minded
people
was mind-blowing and that then you could
even
have a career at it was also um
because i started when i was uh eight at
olden theatre workshop and doing
um core groups and um
i was auditioning really early and doing
pro
am drums and um professional
and um amateur stuff so
i yeah i think once i thought oh i'm
gonna do this
i'm actually going to do this then then
you start to look at i mean julie
walters
um is always someone that i
i think i've cursed to her a couple of
times when i like
been at awards and stuff like that um
and
and then you just learn what what it is
that you you then you get into film
and um and
you start to create your own kind of
want and need and when you figure out
what kind of actor you want to be
and what you don't want to be that is
just like magic
because um i think i spent a lot of time
not knowing
and i knew i wanted to do it and i knew
who i loved and why
but i didn't know what kind of actor i
wanted to be um
i don't think it was until i did
unforgiven and i really settled into
that
um so yeah okay glenda was there one
thing that
sort of pushed you into a into well it
was quite by accident actually i was
working in boots cash chemist and a
friend of mine
and i felt i mean i didn't put it in
these words at that time but i felt
there had to be more to life than i was
living and perhaps i had more to give
that i was being asked to give
and a friend of mine was in one of the
local amateur dramatic societies and she
said come
it's fun so i went and somebody said as
i'm sure someone always does
not me i hate um you should do this
professionally so i wrote to the only
drama school i'd ever had and that's
telescope all that
and the thing that really made me
realize what the theater was in the
sense was i i was very lucky i left
drama school i've got a job in horn
church rep
and there was a matinee on a wednesday
and it was a pensionless matinee
and i can't remember the name of the
play but it was all set in a hospital
ward
and my character only had the one scene
with her back to the audience
telling her fiance who was dying in his
bed
that she'd fallen in love with somebody
else and they weren't going to get
married
right so i go into my spiel this is
pensioners matinee and this voice from
the stalls
says that's very bad acting with your
back to the audience and that sort of
settled it for me i thought
[Music]
there's a lesson there somewhere
[Music]
you